وكما نطال على الشاشه بحسب المصد السوري
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في سوريا الى
1580 قتيلا فرق الانقاذ تركيا مشاهدينا
تواصل عمليه البحث عن ناجين وكما نتابع
الان في هذه الصور المباشره من تركيا حيث
يتواصل عمليات الانقاذ من قبل فرق الانقاذ
للبحث عن ناجيين بين انقاض المباني التي
انهارت بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا الاجماليه مشاهديها
لعدد القتلى في البلدين تجاوزت الاربعه
الاف وثمانمائه بعد هزات ارضيه عنيفه ضربت
مناطق قريبه اذا من الحدود التركيه
السوريه بلغت قوتها سبعه درجات فاصله
ثمانيه اليوم كانت هناك ايضا هزه صباح
اليوم بلغت قوتها خمسه درجات فاصله سته
اداره الكوارث التركيه مشاهدينا اكدت ايضا
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في تركيا الى 3000
والجرحى الى عشرين الف واربعمائه وسته
وعشرين فرق الاغاثه التركيه مشاهدين ايضا
احصت انهيار اكثر من خمسه
الاف600 مبنى في العديد من المدن بينها
مباني من طوابق عده تضم عائلات كبيره كان
افرادها نياما عندما ضرب زلزال الاول
مشاهدينا اذا في متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره لعمليات البحث عن المفقودين تحت
الانقاض في منطقه ديار بكر في تركيا هناك
مخالف مشاهدينا طبعا من ان يستمر عدد
القتلى في الارتفاع بهذه الوتيره خاصه وان
تقديرات منظمه الصحه العالميه تشير الى ان
قرابه عشرين الف شخص ربما يكون قد لقوا
مصرعهم وذلك بحسب تقديرات منظمه الصحه
العالميه
اما في انحاء سوريا مشاهدينا فقد قتل
تقريبا
789 شخصا على الاقل وذلك بحسب وزاره صحه
النظام وايضا بعض فرق الاغاثه الجزاء
المشاهدين الذي ضرب مناطق في سوريا تركز
اكثر بخسائر كبيره ايضا في محافظات كل من
حلب واللاذقيه وحماه وكذلك في طرطوس وريف
ادلب ويشار الى ان الزلزال الاول وقع يوم
الاثنين على عمق نحو 19 كيلومترا فاصله
تسعه وذلك وفقا المعهد الامريكي للمسح
الجيولوجي